- Boozy cereal?
- Bring that to Brooklyn,
white people from all over will be like--
- Oh my gosh!
- Oh my god.
- You better leave this
out the video, man.
- Hey guys, my name is Delisa,
I'm from Texas, and where I come from,
we like to enjoy some boozy cereal.
So I asked around the office
if anybody has tried it,
and no one seems to know
what I'm talking about.
So I'm gonna let them know
how we do it in the South.
The only thing is, they
don't know what's coming.
(record scratch)
- Spiked milk, like, are we getting drunk?
- What?
- It's not even 11 o'clock.
Yo, I've got a job.
- [Interviewer] Bon appetit.
- I don't know, it tastes kind of like
regular milk to me,
which is gonna be weird
if it's spiked with a lot of alcohol.
- There's a faint sock taste.
- Fruity, fruity, fruity
loop, fruity loop...
- Now I taste it.
- It tastes like Froot Loops.
But then the back of my mouth is like,
that tastes like vodka.
- Like, there's a slight
aftertaste of alcohol,
but it's not upsetting me.
Like, it's not gonna stop me from going
through this whole bowl right now.
- This is the classiest one,
I'd say, of all of them.
- You can find me on
Twitter, @IAmDisgusted
because I am disgusted.
- I feel like this is
great for spring break
with your friends, like
we're gonna be day drinkin'
so let's turn up with some drunk cereal.
- This is milk?
- I'm really bad at tasting booze in milk.
Like, I think this is why White Russians
became a thing, is because it's hidden.
- This tastes like dinner.
Like roasted chicken and, like,
rice and peas and string beans.
- Are you sure?
- Yeah.
- I usually think alcohol ruins things,
so I'm so surprised.
Maybe it's just like you
put the right amount in.
- Now it tastes like ham.
And collard greens.
- This is really good,
this is like #adulting.
- I don't know if it's
because I'm excited,
but I kind of feel drunk already.
- At night, as soon as five o'clock hits,
I might like this.
But right now I can't do it.
- I can't taste anything besides
Cinnamon Toast Crunch right now.
- That's a good thing, though.
- Honey Jack and French toast?
That's like a match made in heaven, yo.
- Wheaties are no longer
the breakfast of champions.
Drunk Cinnamon Toast Crunch.
- I would eat this on the beach.
In my finery, just,
like, this and a Speedo.
- See, I really wanna throw
a breakfast party now,
where I invite my friends over,
we watch crappy cartoons,
and get drunk off cereal
and just have fun.
These cereals, they're great.
- I love breakfast, I love booze.
Breakfast, booze, cereal, milk, love it!
Alcohol, awesome!
- I do feel it
in here,
right now.
- Next time I go to the club,
this is what I'm gonna bring.
You just need to put
your milk in the flask,
you get a drink at the
bar, you have your cereal
in your pocket, and you just
put it together on the floor.
- Can't wait for my other meetings today,
I'm totally drunk!